I'm terrified it's happening but that's
a motivating fear that's pressure I
I like pressure I learned that from
Billie Jean King telling my heroes I
remember as a kid watching a press
conference with Billie Jean King and
Bobby Riggs when there yes battle of the
sexes
I was raised by a single mom and I have
three older sisters so I've always
identified with women and I've never saw
women his weak
I only ever knew my strong working
single mother so watching Billie Jean
King was fascinating cuz the way she
carried it they that's what made it work
because he would sit there going you
know why don't you all get back in the
kitchen and the way she carried it was
when it was amazing she didn't sit there
and turn red and get angry she just sat
there like this and then they asked her
how do you feel when he says all this
and she smiled and she said all it does
is put a lot of pressure on me and I
love pressure and she had this big smile
on her face she said I love pressure how
did I thought oh my god
how do you love what does that mean like
I thought really carefully about that
she was like come on keep it calm and I
love it I love it I want this pressure
cuz she knows how to turn pressure into
hard work it motivates her so she's like
go ahead the more he said the more she
had to win she had so much to lose that
she knew she she'd play better so that's
the way I do it and it pushes me life is
short
life is very short I'd like life I like
it I feel like even if it ends up being
short I got I got lucky to get it to
have it because life is an amazing gift
when you think about what you get with a
basic life not even a particularly lucky
life or a healthy life if you have a
life you get to be on earth first of all
oh my god what a location
this is earth and for trillions of miles
in every direction it sucks so bad it's
so that your eyes bolt out of your head
cuz it sucks so bad you get to be on
earth as long as you're not blind or
whatever it is you get to be here you
get to eat food you get to put bacon in
your mouth I mean when you have bacon it
in your mouth it doesn't matter who's
president you just every time I'm eating
bacon I think I could die right now and
I mean it that's how good life is you
just watched two amazing clips from
louis c.k take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]